today on our show batman v superman
stronger and thicker than a dick man the
ultimate edition
ultimate luscious edition today on fat
man on batman
hey we're back you miss us hey it's us
again welcome to fat man batman i'm
kevin smith
bernard a lot of people thought we were
[ __ ] done man but did you give up the
ghost no
never uh we i just went away do some
[ __ ] i went to a film festival showed
yoga hosers and then went to
paris and london showed yogozi's in
london i've been doing some yoga hosers
traveling and stuff
me and mark went and did a live show
indianapolis in indianapolis which was
fun and and the late night show man it
was like the witching hour
totally it was amazing midnight it was
we started the show like [ __ ]
midnight and it was packed
and that it's not like indianapolis like
we got nothing else to do here
i don't know they have a race every once
in a while every 10 minutes you [ __ ]
wait there's a race going on in
indianapolis so there's some other [ __ ]
to do
and we still had a [ __ ] packed house
[ __ ] like let's talk
comics but you can hear that show i
don't know if they shot it i don't know
if we got videos i don't know if they
did
did they ever post that show or no i
think it's on youtube it is
there it is matt checking in producer
matt okay
so never mind where we were let's talk
about where we are man where we are
today
is the week that they release batman
v superman dawn of justice
ultimate edition longest title in the
world a lot of a lot of words on that
skew well you gotta you gotta compensate
for three hours of movie you need a
longer title right you're absolutely
right
three hours of this movie was two and
change in theaters yeah once it was like
220.
they championed the fact that there's
like there's an extra half hour
in this movie and there is i guess i
mean i've seen some there's definitely
stuff that i was like wow i don't
remember that so clearly that's new
lots of like clue trail stuff lots of
lois figuring out where the bullet is
from and lots of clark
going to gotham for the first time yeah
which you know
honestly you know i saw some people
online were like
this makes everything clear
you know like it was the da vinci code
and suddenly like what had been
mysterious is
now the words are glowing on the screen
you guys the letters are moving
everything makes sense
there was a reason um you know some
stuff's cool uh
in terms of the extra stuff but i i
didn't feel like ah
i certainly don't understand why they
got an r but i do remember someone
saying [ __ ]
yeah some like it was incongruous as
[ __ ] it was
i mean you're sitting there watching
this and suddenly somebody's like [ __ ]
him in the ass maybe
that would have been amazing he was
[ __ ] instantly giving the movie like
18 thumbs up
martha this sale of a pep talk that
would have been the thing you don't know
this planet
anything [ __ ] him in the air even better
man she gets [ __ ] saved by batman and
[ __ ] and she's just yelling from the
sidelines [ __ ] him in the ass
[ __ ] with the ass dark knight bruce him
in the geekster
do [ __ ] my son would never do on my
behalf he went crazy
uh for his mom and man of steel so maybe
do you think in this one they were like
look we've already done he went crazy
to save his mom so let's let batman go
crazy to save his mom
because he doesn't have a mom so he's
like adopting the crazy mom
strategy did you [ __ ] hear that like
they honestly
you needed to be in a little egg at the
bottom of that screen
explaining all the motivations you would
have made me enjoy that movie more
that's kind of cool i didn't really
thought about it
adopting the mom rage this is why you
tune into this show this is why i do the
show
so i can learn about movies i've seen
and don't understand apparently
that's a beautiful way to look at it so
you know when of course in the movies
like i promise you martha's not gonna
[ __ ] die
get that [ __ ] out of your mouth and tell
me what you're saying and he says that
she's not gonna die
but that whole scene put through the
prism of like
not again and he [ __ ] goes ape [ __ ]
like literally almost killing everybody
in the room i've seen moms die before
exactly never on my watch exactly i
don't know i like that i like your
version of batman v superman we need the
bernard edition
where you're explaining it'll be an hour
and 43 minutes
well done all right so having re-watched
the movie now
three times on home video uh since
i got it uh and that's like
all three hours plus and stuff
here are my ultimate if you will
feelings on the movie uh the batman
fighty sequences like the one we just
described
unparalleled awesome when you look at
that [ __ ] even though he's like
knifing [ __ ] and in the ultimate
edition
at one point you know somebody [ __ ]
knifes him there's some badass [ __ ] dude
honestly like the [ __ ] fighting when
he saves clark's mom
whole [ __ ] movie should have been
that like it was just insane it was like
watching the cartoon the animated series
it was like watching batman move in ways
that like you've only seen him here
before move
in a video game right when they do the
arkham knight games and they show that
[ __ ] and like
[ __ ] throw that shoots a chord and
yanks a [ __ ] punches him in the
face as he lands
like all those boss stages in you know
injustice gods among us where
you do a special move and [ __ ] that's
what it looked that fluid that smooth
the fighting so i rewatched that [ __ ] a
[ __ ] bunch man it was badass
um and then the other thing i really
liked
that i've rewatched i'm trying to think
of the [ __ ] that made me go back and
re-watch
a couple times the wonder woman sequence
yeah i think it's kind of
you know i'm not gonna be like that's
[ __ ] flawless but it is so fun and
you wish
like more of that less of everything
else like it's so
intense once that music kicks in perfect
music cue for her
and the joy of the fight and like
watching the trinity get together man
watching her like use the
magic lasso and [ __ ] like that we're
like ah
like i was i'm not gonna lie dude as i
watched on my big screen tv
like earlier this morning i rolled a
tear during that [ __ ]
sequence like and not but it wasn't like
oh my god
they've positioned it so emotionally i
was just like
wow my whole life like you know it's
kind of what i wanted
you know what i'm saying like honestly
like holy [ __ ]
and she's just so [ __ ] fearless and
like she cuts the motherfucker's hand
off
like and that one moment where he like
beats her ass tort into the ground and
she [ __ ] like
hits the car and she [ __ ] shakes it
off and she's like you prick and then
heads back at him
shit's gold that shit's gold man like he
definitely should have been in charge of
large sections of that movie
zack snyder because he got that like
right that was really cool
batman fighting was [ __ ] right
but my i think my biggest like now i've
watched a movie a bunch like my biggest
complaint this will never be changed
is i i and this is maybe i'm old school
i can't stand that lex luthor knows who
everybody is yeah he just figured it out
he thought about some stuff and
honestly i don't give a [ __ ] if he's a
super genius or somebody wrote it on a
piece of paper or [ __ ] like
it was revealed by steppenwolf but the
fact that [ __ ] lex luthor knows that
bruce wayne is batman
and not just it's not even like we see
him figure it out no
he walks into the movie knowing that
lois lane
and clark can and superman have a thing
yeah like he never
never earns that knowledge he just has
that knowledge and he tells us this like
later on when he's doing the you know
villain speech and [ __ ] where he's like
all i had to do was do this
and do this and write some letters and
blah blah blah and yeah i remember the
first time i watched the movie i was
like is he [ __ ] saying that he
knows that bruce wayne is batman well
there's that bit in the extended cut
where
where uh where perry white the worst
journalist in the world
okay says and look listen mark works
i know what bad journalists look like
but he comes from legit world of the
press so you have an
insight into that character you're
allowed to say that he's not a great
writer so first i mean perry white
assigns clark kent to sports
for a reason beyond surpassing knowledge
but okay [ __ ] it whatever
but then he says all right so i was to
have you do this other new stuff
but i got a request to send you to the
lex luthor
gala event thing not that he assigned
them like
perry white is is bending to the request
of some
old socialite lady which we clearly know
it's lex luthor who asked clark kent to
show up here
lex luthor knows that clark kent is
going to like
how why does lex know all this [ __ ] this
version of lex
he has like every once in a while he
[ __ ] references like
yeah superman but like there's
this this version never explains to me
why his life is worse
for superman being there yeah like why
do you hate this guy so much
other than him just being superman yeah
so tell me tell me what it is
business version whatever i get why
bruce wayne doesn't like superman yes
like they they make that i may not
necessarily like agree that's
also like minefield
i love batman i love
affleck i love affleck's batman
my my personal preference for a batman
a little less shitty to others
you know a little little i mean he's bad
to the bad guys
but like you know it's it's weird it's i
understand the conceit is to like
they've got to fight
and i understand perfectly the setup
like it
it i'll almost go with you to a certain
point
but the moment like that he's like i'm
gonna kill this [ __ ]
moment murders on the menu that's
you know it's just like well you know i
understand like everyone keeps going
like it's a batman who's
been doing this for 20 years man he's
grizzled and [ __ ] i'm like well
look i read the dark knight returns i
know how that goes i can handle a
grizzled batman i'm not saying i can't
but like
there's no real like you know i guess
the reason the reason for his escalation
where he's like burning criminals and
he's just like
we've always been criminals alfred you
know there's nothing nothing change or
anything like that
but i guess he's intensified because of
the superman thing but like but like a
hero needs
hunting that guy is pretty egregious he
needs to have a line he won't cross
like that is what separates the heroes
from the villains there's a there is a
moral absolute for you a thing you won't
do
batman in this version does not have
that moral absolute
and in and then it's i am a criminal i'm
a vigilante i am everything that i say
that i hate yeah so then
how is that guy somebody i'm gonna root
for but that's when everyone says online
that you know you're an idiot
that's the [ __ ] thing like that's the
story
is his redemption he's a guy who [ __ ]
lost the faith and at the end of the
movie he gets the faith again
and i i got that too i mean i get that
too but if it's going to be death wish
then i need to see that dude before he
has the death wish
maybe that's the problem maybe the
problem is like they're like look
in order to give you this movie we
couldn't give you a zillion years of
batman backstory you know the batman
backstory here's
here's enough here's all you need his
parents got killed and [ __ ] moving on
but yeah maybe you're right maybe you
needed to see like a bit more of the
like piece nick batman before he's
branding people yeah like we need to see
the thing that pushes him over the edge
and it can't just be
like as spoken like oh yeah no he's
pissed off because he's been doing this
for 20 years and it's gotten bad like i
get that it goes bad
i get that there's a batman who is
pushed to the brink
right but i got to see what he was like
before the brink yeah
yeah i'm with you on that man and it
sounds like we're going to see what he's
like
after the break in justice league which
we'll talk about in a second
um i i don't regret buying this and
watching as many times as i have my old
lady the other day was just like how
many times are you going to watch this
and i was like until i [ __ ] love it
it's going to work on me it's going to
[ __ ] happen i'm going to love it
but i'm telling you man like the wonder
woman stuff has
fen is wonderful i mean for lack of a
better word and
the batman stuff is when he's you know
in the third act it's on point once he's
[ __ ] done hating
right and i do like that opening
sequence i think it's pretty powerful
stuff and i think it was very clever
that like
this fits into this moment of that movie
and we can
kind of go back and here's bruce from
the ground watching
the metropolis fall apart as zod takes a
piece by piece to the ground that that
sequence is
like wonderful and [ __ ] it even added
like this this
row of kids being walked out of the the
dmv zone which was cool so that one
girl's like where's your mommy
there's a whole field trip full of
mommies who didn't make it out of this
building yeah see that makes sense too
because there was also this one girl in
the middle of gotham going live
i've got a doll um but yeah you know
they
they they didn't add anything more about
do you can you have you seen it yeah did
they anything
pop i mean i know there's a lot of like
uh who's the girl everyone thought she
was gonna play batgirl
oh jenna malone and she turned out to be
somebody works at star labs
she's like this is bullet it's [ __ ]
weird yeah like it's lots of clue path
stuff it's lots of like here's lois's
investigation to the bullet
and then here's clark's investigation
into gotham city weirdness
into like his whole i'm supposed to
cover a sports game go to gotham and get
the the
the read on the town and then he tries
to find the woman who was testifying on
camera about how
how does what about that like how does
superman choose who to save and who not
to save
and what about that like it opens you
know with the woman is like
he answers to no one not even god i
think you know like
oh my god this i the way i saw in the
original cut of the movie i'm like it's
poor woman's village was seriously
affected
by his intervention in that one scene i
didn't see how there was no village i
saw but
her story is that they got all shitty
after superman left or whatever the [ __ ]
and then somehow tied it into like this
is his fault
you know it's a stretch but they let it
go and the movie went on and then there
are other things to think about bigger
fish to fry
uh but all of a sudden in this version
of the movie
like she's a spy like she's lying
and she gets [ __ ] murdered for it and
like
this shit's like why wasn't that in the
original cut
i'm not crazy writing her script for the
things for her to say on camera
like okay and then has her [ __ ]
killed like that was pretty metal
there's a lot of death in this movie
like people were killed left and right
and when they [ __ ] fight at the end i
know you know they're very quick to
point out
this is abandoned drugger's island is
abandoned nobody's here
abandoned means no one's gonna get hurt
but buildings come down
it becomes kind of disaster porn in the
third act a lot of things get broken and
[ __ ] but
man he like when he soars
he soars zach snyder like there's some
[ __ ] that's like
beautiful absolutely [ __ ] beautiful
and
you know but i'm i'm telling you man my
biggest complaint is always going to be
like
lex if lex luthor if a billionaire
knew if donald trump knew batman's
secret
how like you know what i'm saying even
if they sent him to jail for
[ __ ] trump university or whatever the
[ __ ] that would be his get out of jail
free card he's like
here i'll tell you who batman is and
then you could go get him because he is
a hunted vigilante i know i've done [ __ ]
too but this is what you do in this
system you roll over on somebody else
this guy's been committing crimes for 20
[ __ ] years yeah like i remember
reading
you know who he is i'll tell you if you
let me out of this journal yeah i
remember reading one criticism
that said i would buy this lex luthor
better if he was like a crazy
fundamentalist
christian like if he was if he was a
great idea
he was like a religious fanatic and then
all of this like gods and demons and
against the will of the bible and
outside of scripture and then batman as
this person who's absolutely against
the the tenets of the faith and an alien
like all of that then the hate
the the derision all of that makes sense
but just to be like a rich kid whose
daddy hated him
that's why yeah i'm with you that would
have been hot man if he was just like
religious foreign like then i get it
and then he is threatened by this guy
because he's like this is a god this guy
threatens my belief in jesus because
yeah jesus can't do with this jesus
didn't have heat vision
how am i supposed to sell jesus tomorrow
um i had some people online who were
like you should watch the watch the
extended cut
it will explain everything i saw that a
few times myself and i kept on feeling
like
listen if you have to explain the punch
line of a joke to me
it's not a good joke the joke didn't
work like
the theatrical cut as written like
that's your movie
tell me your movie don't wait for me to
see the stuff you didn't want me to see
at first
to have it make sense there was a lot of
that when the movie's in theaters like
you don't understand man it's dark side
and i'm like yeah okay i get that
because i read the comics but like i
took my kid no idea what any of that was
even watching the extended cut like when
you see like lex in the the belly of
that kryptonian ship and there's a
figure standing over him that's clearly
supposed to be dark side
steppenwolf steppenwolf sorry he's not
gonna know who that is yeah i barely
knew who that was and i read the
comments that's true
it's like even if you watched the
animated series a lot and you were like
oh dark side
he's the big bad from space steppenwolf
is deep cut
yeah like that's that's lean cuts of the
meat but not a lot of people will
understand and from what i understand
that's their villain in justice league
yeah so why
yeah okay sure it's a choice
and i get it well i mean i get it if
justice league was meant to be a
two-parter which is what they
said for a long long time but recently
they sent a bunch of press to the
justice league set right
in england well i was over there i wish
i had known i would have went to the
[ __ ]
set i'm sure they would have been like
mr affleck doesn't want you here
but they've let journalists on set that
didn't like the movie yeah they were
very careful to sort of court
the jury it was it was the charm
offensive basically explained which was
listen we gather you guys specifically
we're shitty about this movie on the
internet
come and see what we're doing now come
and see that we listen to you
that all being said that all being said
the word come back the word that they
purchased
is yes shit's good or it's lighter it's
been writing we realized that the tone
was too dark we're
looking i'm all for that dude like i you
know whenever we get there
i'm happy they got that [ __ ] egg
because i haven't sat through this movie
a few more times
like it is like egregiously [ __ ]
negative and dark
like even right down to [ __ ] like you
know lex luthor is like
we're gonna kill martha if you don't
fight and [ __ ] like that
and the kg beast who's the guy who's
like got his mom there like at one point
lex is like you know we're gonna best
what do you do with a mother of flying
demon is a witch what do you do with a
witch a burner and [ __ ]
you know putting a bullet in her head is
just as [ __ ] fine
but they literally show the [ __ ]
putting on
the [ __ ] the flamethrower which you
know as a guy who grew up reading kg
beast comics
like you know uh what was it four nights
the beast five nights in the niece i
forget what that storyline was
but i was there for the inception of the
character and stuff it was like oh
that's kind of [ __ ] cool to see like
the cruelty already
but again this is a kid's movie kind of
like
and the guy literally sparks and has the
[ __ ] blow to her it's like near her
head
this woman this older woman
like it's just crazy and you're like but
then i guess they're like well that
justifies batman's
serious [ __ ] beat down like because
he comes in and [ __ ] neuters
everybody
and in the in the ultimate cut he pushes
like a guy who stabs him
he pulls he's like ah he pulls the knife
out and he [ __ ] marches the dude back
to the wall
and stabs him into the wall to pin him
kicks a few more asses but then comes
back to the dude with the knife in his
shoulder
and i don't know what happened because
it's under the frame
but he's all close to him and [ __ ] and
all of a sudden he's like
and the guy's like ah and then they cut
away i think what they're saying is he
punched him in the balls
point blank yeah that's the only way to
read that scene
like i don't know what else is being
communicated except he was like
and honestly i respected it because he's
like you [ __ ] knifed me
and i knifed you back and then i had to
go beat somebody but i didn't forget you
[ __ ] knifed me
and that's this is what you get for a
knife
and he [ __ ] like grabs his nuts and
rips them off or something you don't
like him you bring a gun
oh my god chicago he punched him to
death in the balls
and i would imagine that was something
i've always wanted but in the moment i
was watching it i was like i don't know
if i wanted to see this
batman's punching people in the balls
[ __ ] metal dude he was such a [ __ ]
good fighter and [ __ ]
um is they were represented well in the
behind-the-scenes footage they show you
how they
shoot that [ __ ] and it's so weird
because in a lot of moments he's not
wearing a cape at all
mm-hmm and i'll see you later on you
know you have to
you have to these days it's all ball
bearings these days
um okay so the uh in the ultimate
edition also if you look on the behind
the scenes stuff
you'll see more footage of cyborg you
see
more footage of aquaman not more footage
but the shooting of that footage really
um are there well i mean all the deleted
scenes are
contained in the movie yeah there he is
man there's cyborg
uh kind of creepy that they were only
able to save the head and torso look at
that [ __ ]
look at that in the in the daylight dude
that literally looks
like could you imagine seeing that in
real life if i looked like that i would
have my shirt off all the time i can
dude
little bits of i'd wear i'd wear armor
like him but only a little piece over my
dick
the rest of my body would be on display
and they'd be like what's under that
thimble i'd be like you know
you know something small my trident
this is my teaspoon um so
justice league uh report from the set
mark yes is that uh the tone as you said
has been lightened there's a describing
of a scene
between bruce wayne and and i want to
say wally west but it's very own why
why they didn't make it while he was
because barry allen because they don't
love us because
yeah pretty much um but uh the
scene sounded fun and
you know like like here's the thing so
weird that like everybody's like you
know
we're what are you you're more away from
this movie and everyone's like it's
gonna be fun
we got it we figured out you guys people
you will believe a man can smile
thank you that's old school nice job um
but yeah i mean and here's a great thing
that you could do with this bruce wayne
is he could absolutely be the straight
man to everybody else
because he's so [ __ ] grim and so
humorless how you make that work is you
add humor you add
your barry allens you add your vic
stones you add these characters who have
some sense of
life and joy let everybody make a joke
except him
yeah like in the cartoon totally but
i wonder if he would play that affleck
would never let that happen
yeah like i know it'd be like what
everyone else gets to be funny and i
have to be the straight man
i'm that guy what am i suddenly matt
damon [ __ ] this noise
um yeah i can't imagine oh you're johnny
carson you're
you're the guy who just serves up the
the underhand softball but it's so true
and like honestly
like that would be a fun way to do it
too yeah everyone gets to shine and you
get to be
like that's what you remember remember
the black hole justice league
international jli and jayla kevin what's
his name two dudes
mcguire and giving to mcguire's [ __ ]
league
their batman was like [ __ ] serious as
a heart attack
one punch yes yes oh my god he [ __ ]
punched out guard gardner we still
talk about it it didn't even happen to
us in high school it happened on a page
and we still talk about it
but it was pitch perfect because he was
so the dark knight and everybody else
around him was like having a good time
and so it made him even more enjoyable i
hope they do that
just yeah like he should hope they don't
make him a joker too no cause god you
don't want that you need that dude to be
like the black center of gravity that
everything revolves around
and you always know he's there you
always know he's affecting everything
but he doesn't have to crack a joke
to get a laugh and that's the key if
they do that then we win if it's just a
lot of
more why do you say that name they'll
never mention that name again
no that's that's what i if i was on that
junket i'd been like you played a martha
card again this time
they'd hear back double quick no no
there's no marthas
yeah no she's dead now we wrote a virus
to kill all the martha's in this
universe there's no more marthas
um i will say this though as i watched
that sequence
um like it bordered
on moving um you know almost almost
there like i saw what they were going
for you know people so many people on
twitter are like you don't get it
just because they're [ __ ] both their
moms are named martha
i'm like i got that i understood that
but his turnaround is like
like he's just staggered by the
revelation of a name or that
that he like backs up this thing that
looks like a man
talks like a man walks like a man and
just happens to be a little more
powerful
like you know he's like it must die it
can't be human
it's an animal like you know when he's
giving him the [ __ ] about like you were
never a man
the men are brave and paulie carries him
by his [ __ ] hair and [ __ ]
he's so unnecessarily brutal and it's
not
until you know lois lane's like he had a
mother that suddenly the guy's like
oh my god oh [ __ ] oh i'm the [ __ ]
oh i'm joe chill [ __ ] god damn it um
yeah but anyway it sounds like [ __ ]
in the next movie
none of that you know and i think that
this was also part of the jeff johns
being promoted to
like the head the co-head of dc films
amen dude
because that's that's it feels like
their reaction to and when i say i guess
the warner bros reaction to
studio the motion picture reaction to
batman v superman was to finally let the
guy who knows the most about
all this stuff who's on the payroll and
in the credit to your movie
you know be like uh maybe we shouldn't
do that
right maybe we should do this he
shouldn't have to be the guy barking in
the corner being like guys i know what
to do here
yeah it's okay we got it it sounds like
after
the movie came out they were like we get
it you're kevin feige
go and you know it feels and that's
that's the guy you want like honestly
the reason we all
or i love the flash as much as i do is
because he did something to that
character's backstory
he rewrote he gave that character a
backstory he did the same thing with hal
jordan he was a big
hal jordan fan and the green lantern
corps and stuff he's loved dc forever
man so the
jeff has done amazing work on
getting these characters to a place
where he can
sit there i've seen him do it a number
of times and talk about
what's special about each in terms of
like you know it's not just like hey
they're all a bunch of superheroes
they'll sit there and break it down
where he's like flash allows you to do
time travel stories it allows you to
multi-dimensional stories so the canvas
you can
draw on is massive batman allows you to
do
you know urban crime superman allows you
to do like you know
jesus with a cape and in space wonder
woman allows you the same thing but you
know
mythology and brings you into that
[ __ ] world and
green lantern brings you into space so
like he's so eloquent about all this
all this dc stuff and all these
characters
let the boy in and it seems like that's
what's
happened now because he's like he's over
there he's been over in london quite a
bit and stuff and
you know
last time i was like he's writing the
movie with affleck and that became a
news story
but i thought everybody knew that
because it was in the press before
right but i guess nobody paid attention
they were like oh my god confirmation
it was confirmed because i read it in
your news report um
but it sounds like you know jeff's deep
into that too it just sounds right
everything about this sounds right if
you got
some dude that you if you had to pick
somebody in charge all this
that's your man and that's the dude
who's gonna [ __ ]
give you like we go to see the justice
league movie we're gonna be like ah
that's gonna be it will at least
feel right yeah yeah and then i mean
whatever else issues i might have batman
v superman
it was that it didn't feel right like
i'm okay with movies that aren't like
the best movie ever in the world that's
why we're friends yeah
but at least you know it needs to feel
like it's the right thing
or like you knew what you were trying to
make going in any number of errors can
happen in execution but
going in you got to feel like all right
that feels like a captain america movie
that feels like a batman movie that
feels like a superman movie you know
what that should feel like and when it
doesn't
that's when the audience kind of turns
this felt like a wonder woman movie in
the last
yeah like because that was the bit
you're excited about yeah holy [ __ ]
bring me more of that
it's cool man it was really cool and
they showed in the behind the scenes
footage some movie footage of wonder
woman
movie as well some fighty fighty and
some also like i'm in the 20s or
whatever
um yeah so the dc universe is just
getting bigger and bigger next up
squad there's some suicide squad footage
too on the
ultimate edition uh blu-ray which is
well worth
your time look you love this [ __ ] you
gotta support this [ __ ] man i don't mean
that like medicine and chicks some
people get shitty about that they're
like [ __ ] you i don't have to do nothing
fine
not talking to you and also don't let a
stranger tell you what to do but
as a fan of this stuff i bought it
digitally man i bought it months ago
when they put it up on itunes and then
bang i got it on the deck um they've got
on the
dvd on the blu-ray apparently my dc oh
yeah your
thing with jeff johns as well you know
your hall of justice tour yes
yes so that's there as well so go out
and get it man because we all wanted
these movies and now they're happening
yeah i mean good bad or indifferent like
we're getting them right like and that's
what we've always wanted
i mean even if they're bad they're
putting that on the phone good bad and
different
that's on the justice league tag line
good bad and different you're getting
this movie
i'm excited for that movie man i don't
need no [ __ ] people go over to
england and be like yeah i vouch for it
and [ __ ]
look we're all self-correcting animals
in this on this planet
you know they looked at there was a lot
of [ __ ] people bitching
and they were like okay this is a
mainstream product like a lot of people
[ __ ] about tusk or yoga hosers i don't
do [ __ ] because it's like you don't have
to see this it's not part of your
[ __ ] homework or anything like that
when you are working with these
characters yeah you're like you gotta
you gotta get everybody it's nerd
homework
you'll have to see it oh and there's
rules and stuff and so
you know apparently i i i got that right
away i only have to hear from anybody to
know that like
everybody behind closed doors was
probably like all right well
next time let's be let's have a little
more fun
and they're smart to do that man and now
they got [ __ ] jeff insurance so it's
all good
and sounds like the footage that's
coming out of [ __ ] england so far
they're happy with so yeah watch batman
v superman ultimate edition man if you
buy the digital version
i imagine you buy the blu-ray version
they give you both you get the
theatrical cut and the [ __ ] 18-hour
cut as well
um get it watch it man make up your own
mind and stuff
but i'm telling you the thing that i've
gravitated to over and over again
is the wonder woman sequence as soon as
one woman gets in it's like ah and
batman also saving clark's mom there's
some just some
really good stuff in this movie a lot of
people were like there's some good stuff
in this
movie man go and enjoy it at home paul
you could pause
and go do other things and then come
back i love to consume movies that way
man
you could not pause go and do other
things and come back and it'll still be
playing
but you're absolutely right you could do
that as well uh there it is folks uh
that's all we're
talking about for this week for fat man
i'm batman kevin smith mark bernard come
back next week same fat time same fat
channel where is that
youtube.com kevin smith here's
monkeys.com
either or
hey man it's me kevin smith thanks for
watching do me a favor click that thing
below that says subscribe
every time you click that you save a
baby kitten from murder